chris pratt is fully aware of the online
hate being thrown at him and now he's
speaking out welcome everybody to
entertainment tonight yeah chris is
opening up about his parenting
controversy religious misconceptions and
the truth behind his full-body
transformation
the first transformation of my body to
become star-lord was the hardest because
i had the furthest to go i was almost
300 pounds and never really thought that
i would ever be a candidate to play one
of these sort of action hero kind of
roles
when i was andy i was pretty unhealthy i
can't believe that i would eat
five cheeseburgers
for lunch and i lived in like a constant
state of oh god freaking sick of eating
so much and now it's the exact opposite
the super healthy actor is chugging
cheese balls curling dumbbells and
jumping in the pool for his men's health
cover story he's also firing back at the
haters who have made him a target on
twitter you know the worst hollywood
chris meme demanding one has to go god
is real
god loves you
the actor says i didn't know that i
would kind of become the face of
religion when really i'm not a religious
person the 43 year old has been
criticized for his alleged association
with the hillsong church which some
consider to be anti-gay there's this
great quote that i actually heard in
church and it felt
like it really appropriate which was
if the spotlight that's shining on you
is brighter than the light that that
comes from within you it'll kill you
chris tells the magazine out july 5th
i've never actually been to hillsong i
don't know anyone from that church he
added that he sometimes attends the zoe
church as well as a catholic church
where his wife catherine schwarzenegger
attended growing up the father of three
also revealed he cried over the backlash
after this instagram post the actor
posted a loving tribute to catherine and
their healthy daughter he says quote and
then a bunch of articles came out and
said that's so cringe-worthy i can't
believe chris pratt would thank her for
a healthy daughter when his first child
was born premature that's such a dig at
his ex-wife and i'm like my son's gonna
read that one day he's nine and it's
etched in digital stone it really
bothered me
last week catherine shared a glimpse of
her second baby with chris eloise
christina this motherhood chapter has
just been truly incredible for me and
i've enjoyed every single minute of it
and then of course to see my husband
step into a role of being a girl dad is
so beautiful as well by the grace of god
i've got a very understanding and loving
wife is jack in love with being a big
brother now yeah he does a great job as
a big brother yeah uh you know he's nine
and uh my two girls are
21 months and just a month now and so
sweet with them and they miss him when
he's gone and they love him so much
[Music]
you